meaux jean pascal merci d'être là mon
chéri jean-pascal ya beaucoup beaucoup
de réactions sur terre on arrivait et
bonjour pascal bien sûr tu craches la
grande arrivée en septembre avec nous
avec le public avec le grand plateau et
c'est là n'en a pas envie que tu sois
avec nous dès maintenant parce que pour
voilà pour souder l'équipe dès
maintenant mon chéri je te le dis merci
à vous dix mois - jerry qu'est ce qui
t'a fait venir dans tpm pays est ce que
tu peux raconter aux gens moi je raconte
tout donc tu peux tout dire comment ça
s'est passé entre nous dit la vérité
il s'est simplement le contrat le le
salaire était vraiment non c'est vrai
que tu veux avancer ont séparés par
texto on s'est parlé on se connaît
depuis très longtemps qui arrivait à
évoluer et tu es un exemple pour
beaucoup par rapport à ton évolution et
quand tu m'as parlé de voilà d'essayer
d'intégrer l'équipe
on s'est échangé à échanger en a parlé
moi j'ai trop vite tout de suite dit oui
parce que parce que j'ai envie de voler
le côté moi et moi je vais te dire moi
je pense et je te jure après je peux me
tromper
et moi je te regarde et de 6 12 coeurs à
la base alors tu sais qu'il m'avait
demandé de la mrc qui m'avait demandé de
l'animé 12 coeurs aussi c'est vrai je te
jure que c'est vrai les bombes et et je
me rappelle je t'avais vu l'animé je
t'avais trouvé excellent je trouve que
très très très bon d'animation et je
pense que depuis toutes ces années je te
jure que c'est vrai j'ai pensé quand je
pense à toi lise et je pense qu'il a
besoin d'une famille mine de rien parce
que je pense que tu as un énorme
potentiel que tu vas faire bien sûr et
pmp avec nous mais je suis sûr que tu
peux faire plein d'autres choses avec
nous derrière et que vraiment été un mec
qui a énormément de talent je pense
quelqu un très bon animateur donc au
delà d'être un bon chroniqueur ce que je
pense je pense que tu es un bon
animateur et je suis persuadé qu'on va
pouvoir faire plein de choses avec toi
sur s'est vite et moi en tant que
producteur avec toi parce que je crois
énormément en toi et c'est pour ça aussi
je voulais que tu intègre l'équipe et ça
fait longtemps que je suis tu le sais
mon chéri 3 je vais faire des reply
c'est du kif l'afrique est rare qu est
rare chez quelqu'un qui fait de
l'animation c'est que les hommes le
kiffe pas ce qu'il dit ça pour être un
bon pote la srm le trouve charmant est
sérieux il a plein qualité donc les
hommes et les femmes de kif
alors alors bon tu vois que les
chroniqueurs te quitte on va voir si tu
connais bien jean pascal je vais te
poser des questions à chaque fois que tu
répondras mal j'enlèverai donc un petit
bateau n'est d'en haut ce sont des
ballons avec de l'eau que traîne
jean-michel
mère au pied depuis près de dix ans voir
si tu connais bien les chroniqueurs rép
un indice ça se mange un hameçon il peut
le manger chaud pour attraper les
gonzesses enlève un téléski sympa pouces
et bien sûr jean michel meurtre n avait
pas de salle et on arrête là c'est bon
jean pascal baudry aller si on peut
s'occuper dans ce cas le change est
prête à lui des affaires les chiens il
c'est exceptionnel mais moi je m'y
attendais pas le comble